boy what do I geek out on uh there's guy
named J Frank who I have stolen from
quite frequently he I don't even know
how you would describe him he's a writer
he's sort of a professional internet
famous person he does projects on the
internet but there there there there
there they exist on so many different
levels they're really interesting you
know he made he made an earth sandwich
once and he set up a piece of software
where you could plug in your coordinates
and it would tell you the spot opposite
on the opposite side of the globe and
would show you on a map where that was
and then people signed up and
coordinated with each other sort of a
contest and two groups of people on
opposite sides of the planet arranged at
the same time to lay a piece of bread
down on the spot on the globe that was
opposite that so they made an earth
sandwich and you know it's a perfect
example of the kind of stuff that zey
does you know he uses technology to
bring complete strangers together for an
absolutely ridiculous project that
somehow still has a lot of hurt to it so
uh let's see what else you know my
friend John Hodgman I feel bad I feel
bad mentioning him because everybody's
gonna think I'm mentioning him just
because he's my friend but I think he's
an incredibly talented writer and
comedian and he is another person that I
I think just creates really terrific
stuff that that makes you laugh and
sometime later makes you cry because
it's ridiculous but it's also true I'm a
big admirer of his work uh what else oh
gosh put me on the spot here
okay go I think there may be a little
more mainstream now those guys are those
guys are pretty famous but and it seems
trite to even talk about their music
videos because I think most people agree
that they are awesome but you know every
every time a new video comes out i think
that they i am amazed that they have
been able to top themselves and again
it's sort of taking it you know they
start with a very simple concept these
are frequently pretty low budget videos
but it's it's that perfect it's that
perfect concept that that you can you
can somehow do quite a lot with even
though it's a very small idea and you
know their music is great too but i
think they they are just super super
creative talented people on all fronts
and i'm very jealous of them